au cabaret voulez-vous aux côtés de
laurent des caves le patron metteur en
scène il y à une personne incontournable
c'est maxime courilleau le maître de
chorégraphie cet après midi ils
procèdent avec ses danseurs aux derniers
réglages avant la représentation du soir
l'as déjà au peut-être face et là tu vas
à ta place
et là tu vas à ta place parce que
visuellement on ne voit trois fois sur
place et une fois tu te déplaces et en
plus tu es capture et tue reste hyper
longtemps de dos parce que du coup tu te
déplaces de dos et tu te tournes au
dernier moment pour mieux faire l'
inverse
maxime pur produit du volet vous apporte
sa touche personnelle
il s'attache avant tout à créer une
bonne synergie
j'essaye de créer une atmosphère propice
au travail mais toujours dans la bonne
humeur dans la bonne entente et ça passe
aussi par des discussions pendant
l'échauffement ont toujours un type en
train de discuter savoir comment ça va
en fonction de ça voilà je suis pas
aussi exigeant
si quelqu'un n'est pas très en forme
parce qu'il est là quand même il faut
que ce soir elles assurent le spectacle
donc il se gère un peu pendant la
répétition niveau énergie puis au
contraire ce qui déborde d'énergie
parfois faux la canaliser un peu en
disant c'est bien mais écarte sens pour
ce soir du coup c'est en parlant et en
échangeant tous ensemble qu'on arrive à
un peu à voir dans quel état d'esprit on
est les uns les autres et on se sert de
tout ça pour créer une énergie groupe en
fait qui soit cohérente avec tous
on attaque par animals c'était près
détendu mais aussi pointilleux voir
perfectionniste car maxime courilleau a
aussi la pression son show prophétie ne
ressemble en rien un spectacle de
cabaret traditionnels alors il est
scrutée de près un véritable challenge
pour le jeune chorégraphe de vouloir
être novateur de vouloir être avant
gardiste de vouloir être premier dans un
domaine où peu de gens s'aventurer au
départ c'est ça qui m'a plu enfin je me
suis dit que c'était hyper audacieux et
vachement culotté de de vouloir ouvrir
un établissement enfin d'avoir un
établissement comme ça avec tant de
modernité autant d' avance sur ce qu'ils
peuvent faire dons il est l'heure pour
maxime de revêtir son habit de danseurs
mais il garde un oeil attentif au
moindre détail avant pendant et après le
show
[Musique]